c'est la prison à vie sans possibilité
de libération avant 75 ans agronome de
18 ans a été condamné à la prison à
perpétuité
vol fusillade meurtre des crimes
crapuleux des faits divers qui nous
inquiète et nous aider
pour le public leur sort est réglé
l'histoire est terminée pour le
condamner elle ne fait que commencer
que se passe-t-il derrière ces barbelés
peu de personnes peuvent en témoigner et
c'est voulu les détenus sont confiés aux
soins du service correctionnel du canada
calm mandat de les réhabiliter cette
agence n'est pas reconnu pour sa grande
transparence ou les avocats ordre
carcéral on est souvent les seuls qui
ont la capacité de rapporter qu'est ce
qui se passe à l'intérieur des murs à
l'intérieur des murs il y à la prison
dans la prison
le trait ou des détenus sont enfermés 23
heures sur 24 ce sans contact ils
pressent
une forme de torture de détenus est
isolé d humaniser jusqu'à en perdre la
raison ça se passe dans nos pénitenciers
ici au canada
ce coquet la ségrégation à n'est pas
terrible sur les gens quand je suis allé
dans des prisons givet des gens qui
essayent de s'arracher les yeux de ce
tailladé le corps ou d'étaler des
extraits main sur le mur ne sera plus la
tête contre les murs et sur toi
on n'est vraiment pas guantanamo le
service correctionnel du canada scc
combettes mat ce faire
je passe pour que ces deux-là tard
faisant valoir que la torture ne
torturent ou pas l'impact est réel pour
ceux qui la subissent
chaque demeure et je sors avec deux sacs
de mad ce traitement jugé cruel et
inusité a été aboli en novembre 2019 et
remplacé par un nouveau modèle mais ce
changement historique ce but est une
culture solidement ancrées
ma pratique m'amène à devoir est en
déplacement à tous les jours l'avocate
alexandra paquet défend des criminels
qui ont une cote de sécurité maximale
pourquoi vous intéressez cette clientèle
il ya personne qui ne s'est inclinée en
disant moi je vais être qui ne laisse
pas vraiment on n'est pas terminée à
l'épicé société toujours un contexte il
nous raconte leur enfance et je dirai
toujours atroce et dur en tant que
médecin devenu habitué d'entendre ce
genre de l'histoire le messali salut
développe une certaine carapace
j'imagine une carapace qui la protège
aussi contre certains agents
correctionnels les savent très bien il
le dit avec un parce que tu présentes la
carte devant euros cela m'est arrivé de
faire dire à un client qui sait comment
une escorte c'est juste pour
commentaire grade suivent évidemment
qu'il y aurait jamais dit cela me fera
jamais jamais
généraliser pour que tous les agents
sont commencées en e10 excellent
un événement très conservateur de
toujours être en confrontation mais
voici ce à face à lavaur adéquat se
mettaient elles visitent un de ses
client détenu au pénitencier de
sainte-anne-des-plaines nous n'irons pas
plus loin personne ne va plus loin
l'ancien enquêteur correctionnelle en
sait quelque chose
ces hauts murs qui entourent les prisons
ils ne sont pas seulement construit pour
garder les gens à l'intérieur mais aussi
pour empêcher les gens d'y entrer c'est
l'environnement opérationnel dans lequel
des pénitenciers fonctionne
la prison est une micro société avec ses
propres règles
son code de conduite sa hiérarchie
frédéric lebeau connaît bien ce milieu
il y travaille depuis 22 ans la majorité
des détenus respecte les règles
respectent leurs conditions de détention
respecte leur claque à l'action l-1 un
bon comportement un comportement de
changement un comportement qui volent à
vingt et un accent réfractaires il y en
a qui ne veulent pas changer et anouk
pour eux le crime paie la criminalité
continuez continuez
votre visite n'est vraiment pas
nécessaire pour les réfractaires le
châtiment a déjà été beaucoup plus
brutale comme me le rappelait les
minutes du patrimoine suis ici pour les
voir que vous le souhaitiez nous
la députée agnès maltais la première
femme élue à la chambre des communes
s'est battu pour que cesse le châtiment
corporel ce n'est qu'en 1972 que cette
punition jugées inhumaines sera abolie
[Musique]
pouvions-nous gérer en toute sécurité
une prison sans faute et les gens des
personnes ont témoigné de manière
sincère et passionné du risque que cela
représente 7 si nous faisions
à quel point nos prisons devient
dangereuse pour les hommes et les femmes
qui travaillent
le trou a remplacé le fouet
le détenu est séparée de la population
générale placée dans l'aisne d'isolement
où il est confiné à sa cellule 23 heures
sur 24 tout est resté deux jours de ce
monde deux mois certains sont restés
plus bidon
oui effectivement c'est un travail zalma
préventif il m'a dit qu'il en est à deux
jours du travail qui était servi c'est
généralement le cas quand on veut isoler
des détenus sous les trois principes
sains pour la propre sécurité la
sécurité de l'établissement où la
sécurité d'un autre codétenu c'est un
outil pour nous c'était vraiment un
outil qui est l eau qui étaient
fonctionnels qui fonctionnait bien vous
dis pas qu'il n'ya pas de changements
apportés à leur logement que van damme a
pris seul la décision d'abroger les
allemands
au début on croyait pas à 5 au début
tous les agents collection est un peu
crédule à cet effet leur dis que ça
n'existe plus depuis que le monde est
monde que seul existe pour nous jetons
un rapport de sécurité
[Musique]
s'il isolement existe depuis que le
monde est monde ça fait presque aussi
longtemps qu on connaît les effets
dommageables sur la santé mentale des
techniques
incarcéré depuis 2002 olivier du thabor
connu une trentaine de placement en
isolement une cellule de deux mètres sur
trois la grandeur d'un espace de
stationnement où chaque heure se
ressemblent ce soir
encore plus con et déjà
les portes d'accès 10 10 à faire en
sorte que mon niveau augmente mais pas
que puis amener ça fait juste que le
drake shot aurait fait sauter puis moi
quand thomas sabbath et j'avais
l'impression de sortie
et présente rouge ça fait qu'ils ont
menacé le sera fort bien sûr moi
kim peek a longtemps dirigé l'organisme
elizabeth fry qui défend les droits des
détenus maintenant sénatrice elle
poursuit sa bataille elle a rencontré
des centaines de détenus
entre la recherche internationale a
montré que même quelques heures
isolement peuvent causer une privation
sensorielle qui vous nuit physiquement
voulu neurologiquement psychologiquement
ce n'est que cinq ans depuis
[Musique]
oui si nous voyons des gens devenir
paranoïaque il croit que les murs se
referme sur eux s'ils ne font pas
confiance aux gens qui sont responsables
des ils ont peur ils ont de l'anc site
est pire encore
mais les effets négatifs sur la santé
mentale lorsque les effets négatifs de
l' isolement ces documents c'est est ce
que les services correctionnels parce
que le constater chez d'état ont parlé
sous l'ancien régime ouais
mais là honnêtement pauvres et gg peut
étudier cette question le long de
l'entrevue aujourd'hui le c'est pas
quelque chose que qu'on exploite
ses soutes s'allonger mais pas que
puisque logique assure le maire
concernant halo pas être facile mais
y'en as raison pour ça une raison pour
assurer sa propre sécurité pour assurer
la propre sécurité de l'établissement ou
même des dodgers à l'intérieur c'est ce
n'est pas que
au canada deux cours d'appel ont jugé
isolement cellulaire inconstitutionnelle
et contraire à la charte des droits les
effets de l'isolément prolongées sont
disproportionnées parce qu'ils exposent
les détenus aient des séquelles graves
et potentiellement permanente
moi j'ai des clients qui est justement
après avoir passé cinq jours en
isolement préventif et ont perdu la
carte complètement et dont un certain
que ça revient mais ça laisse des traces
le suspect albert du terreau ville
l'ancienne amie de la femme chez roger
open de ses clients seraient un de ceux
qui a passé le plus de temps en
isolement au canada ces séjours en
isolement ne se calcule pas en semaines
ou en mois mais en années
passées
[Musique]
sur cette vidéo on voit albert du
terreau ville se faire rouer de coups
pour sa sécurité et demande d'être placé
en isolement
quelqu'un qui évidemment est isolée près
le contact avec des humains que je sois
des agents correctionnels ou des mêmes
des avocats et encore moins sa famille
donc c'est quelqu'un qui est très très
très isolée qui
mais évidemment ça ni avec son lot de
problématiques
[Musique]
ça serait quoi les effets négatifs on se
sent seul
[Musique]
suppose de couleur
sous le
choc
[Musique]
depuis le début de son incarcération
albert du terreau ville a fait l'objet
d'évaluation psychiatrique qui ont
décelé des problèmes de santé mentale
[Musique]
parce que vous avez peur
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec un adulte
comme ça
en gardant en prison toute sa vie parce
que y'a par d'interagir avec les autres
ans qu'est ce qu'on fait elle est où la
ligne à
la peine la moins cruel et unicité pl -
privative de liberté et la sécurité du
public parce que dans son côté se sont
vraiment dans la ruche j'aime mettre
marie claude lacroix a aussi des clients
qui demandent isolement pour assurer
leur propre protection
la seule option viable pour sa survie
qu'il voit c'est de demeurer en
isolement mais ça veut pas dire pour
autant qu'il consent à être dans des
conditions telles qu'ils vont affecter
sa santé mentale maintenant c'est du
devoir du service correctionnel d'offrir
des absences viable à ces individus leur
pour qu'ils puissent cheminer dans un
environnement qui affectera pas leur
santé mentale
le nombre de détenus placés en isolement
a varié selon les années en 2013 par
exemple on pouvait compter une moyenne
quotidienne de 800 détenus en isolement
près de 6 % de la population des prisons
fédérales des critiques des rapports
cliniques des poursuites et même un
blâme des nations unies ont ramené de
services correctionnels à diminuer
l'usagé des cellules d'isolement depuis
2014 mais sans jamais les fermer pour
plusieurs observateurs ça ne pouvait
plus durer
[Musique]
depuis qu'il est incarcéré
timothée aurait vécu l'équivalent de
cinq années en cellule d'isolement
est-ce que c'est arrivé des journées où
vous ne parliez à personne
paléo qu'un personnes souvent la sema
keynésienne de défense aussi c'est
intense et plus il fait juste formidable
bush est trop trouver un jour une
carapace est caché un métacarpe un
espoir tout cas la baffe étrange tentant
jusqu'à le temps là pour durer et
ouverture d'un dans le papier la chine
nos mains mais il m'a donc on est moche
et punch et ont biffé
cette folie comme il dit même menés à
l'automutilation il ya des tentatives de
suicide et comme c'est le cas pour
plusieurs détenus le trou n'a fait
qu'exacerber cette frustration augmente
et sa violence
les par le mexique abbas ok mais là
c'est qu'ils simplifient la c1 en cui
les distorsions cognitives la mauvaise
qu'importe la méfiance tout est encore
plus solide avec des dessins de gâchis
des dynamiques sera année après année
après année
après des années en centre jeunesse
olivier entre au pénitencier en 2012 il
n'a que 18 ans il aurait connu une
trentaine de placement en isolement
[Musique]
je suis
très solide
et par michelin
à chaque placement en isolement son
anxiété s'aggrave
n'ont pas de compteur s'était pas
suicidé et garder ça à l'esprit occupé
seulement
du groupe et non pas parce qu'il faut
pas oublier ont passé haut la tête
[Musique]
tu pas ce qu'ils voulaient pas de
printemps pour
se libérer de son anxiété olivier a
commencé à se tourner utile et il a
aussi fait deux tentatives de suicide
[Musique]
j'étais tendu la main sérieux qui avait
soulevé
le frère d'olivier stéphane a lui aussi
vécu plusieurs séjours en isolement
incarcérés dans des pénitenciers
différents les deux frères écrivait j'ai
tellement eu de
daychopan qui sentait bon pied
dès qu'ils ont nécessité
et mango j'aimerais avec toi pour nous
ça fait longtemps
chez paul fraisse je vais vraiment 2022
un garde me dit si je mange avec le
septième à mourir
je commence et écuries de cette vie de
mario je t'aime jatta petit nouvelle
steph
le 17 décembre dernier alors qu'il était
dans une cellule de surveillance 24
heures sur 24 en cas de suicide stéphane
est retrouvé mort la cause de son décès
et qualifié de non naturelle
des enquêtes sont en cours dont une du
bureau du coroner de l'ontario ce n'est
pas la première fois qu'un corner se
penche sur une mort suspecte en
isolement
[Musique]
l'histoire daschle et se mettent à
choquer les canadiens cette jeune femme
de 19 ans s'est suicidé en 2007 sous le
regard des agents correctionnels
[Musique]
elle avait reçu une peine de 30 jours
pour avoir lancé des pommes un facteur
une fois en détention son comportement
lié à ses problèmes de santé mentale a
eu pour effet d'alourdir sa peine
elle aura passé plus de 1000 jours en
isolement
à la suite de son décès un corner avait
recommandé l'abolition de l'isolément
cellulaire le service correctionnel
avait alors refusé pour des raisons de
sécurité
[Musique]
en 2015 les nations unies adopte les
règles nelson mandela selon ces normes
plus de quinze jours en isolement
équivaut à de la torture
ou services correctionnels ne va abolir
l'isolément cellulaire que quatre ans
plus tard
qu'est ce qui a amené services
correctionnels à l'abolir
a fait en 2019 on abolit les allemands
préparatifs donc ça n'existe plus comme
mesure où les collectionnait du canada
et on a mis en oeuvre un nouveau modèle
mais qu'est ce qui a amené cette
décision là un nouveau modèle qui
qui apporte une nouvelle approche une
approche où on mise sur l'intégration et
au niveau de la livraison programme
ce que le service correctionnel ne dit
pas c'est qu'il n'a pas vraiment eu le
choix les tribunaux ont jugé que les
mesures d'isolement sont un traitement
cruel et inusité qui enfreint la charte
canadienne des droits et libertés
ils ont donné un an gouvernement pour
qu'il change la loi
de plus toi recours collectifs viennent
d'accorder 28 millions $ à plusieurs
milliers de détenus qui ont connu du
helmand je pense que quand services
correctionnels où le gouvernement
canadien se retrouve devant les
tribunaux à devoir payer des sommes
d'argent considérables à des personnes
incarcérées que ça pousse que ça pose au
changement malheureusement je pense que
s'en sort on serait probablement pas
rendus en tête une nouvelle mode on fait
des records que l'excès fait contre les
services correctionnels à grandes
pelletées ça devient difficile pour les
agents correction ça devient difficile
de devoir se d'avoir tout lé groupe de
pression utilisé la porte des tribunaux
peuvent amener des changements majeurs
au service correctionnel
ça devient difficile
le 30 novembre 2009 le fédéral aboli
isolement cellulaire il crée les unités
d'intervention structurer les us qui ne
devront être utilisés qu'en dernier
recours et pour une durée la plus courte
possible
selon ces nouvelles règles un détenu en
ubs doit sortir de cellule au moins
quatre heures par jour pendant cette
période de temps on doit lui offrir deux
heures de contacts humains significatif
des échanges avec des codétenus des
travailleurs sociaux des agentes
programme
concrètement vous dire honnêtement
c'était une initiative
très emballant pour les services
correctionnels du canada donc on nous
fournit avec ce nouveau modèle une
occasion d'être abonné est vraiment
travaillé sur le réadaptation et leur
réintégration à cahan population
carcérale régulière ultima ça joue en
plein dans notre monde qui les appuie
dans leur réintégration nous la société
canadienne est d'assurer la sécurité
publique je pourrais peut-être juste
renchérit en disant que tu as été vu
comme une opportunité d'être avant
gardiste de gérer les risques
différemment
les unités d'intervention structurés
sont créés dans caisse de 43 pénitencier
surtout ceux à sécurité maximale
les agents correctionnels dénonce le
manque de sanctions efficaces face aux
mauvais comportements dans notre rôle
d'agent de correction faut modifier les
comportements donc oui c'était un pas
important qu'on a perdu malheureusement
qu'on ne put classé quoi qui remplace et
ça c'est des amendes cd perte de
privilèges mais donner des amendes à des
détenus qui n'ont pas d'argent
absolument
après trois mois d'attentes en raison de
l'accord vide le service correctionnel
nous donne finalement accès aux unités
d'intervention structure et du centre
régional de réception
c'est dans cet établissement que les
détenus attendent leur cote de sécurité
avant d'être assigné à un autre
pénitencier
nous n'aurons qu'une heure de tournage
on nous prévient qu'il ne sera interdit
de filmer des agents et des détenus de
toute façon il n'y a personne la rangée
les cellules ont été repeintes en
prévision de notre tournage les
graffitis ont disparu nous comprenons
rapidement que notre visite ne nous
apprendra rien sur le fonctionnement des
unités d'intervention
olivier a fait des séjours en us dans
différents pénitencier à travers le pays
c'est une forme d'une feinte une forme
d'isolement qui
maquille et
mekki meilleur je veux te [ __ ] ce qui
appartient à ses envies finale et
l'exotisme à lui s y avait encore bravé
que marché vraiment à sa gauche tu
t'arrêtes en 2004
[Musique]
si tu étais pas quelqu'un qui m'était
avec des agences jean
[Musique]
calas revenus doivent parler
avec vos
contacts
sur les
laisser à nous
[Musique]
peaceful
quatre heures par jour hors cellule le
temps de prendre une douche de marché
dans la cour extérieure de se distraire
avec des codétenus ou des membres du
personnel c'est la loi donc on n'a pas
le choix font les sentiers quatre heures
par jour c'est quand y'en a plus de
types de population c'est là que ça
devient difficile à gérer suite à des
altercations et déclarez vos ça peut
arriver qu'on est différents types de
population à l'intérieur de ces une
telle aura donc des blocs de 4 armes on
en a quatre sur un 16 ans régulier
est-ce qu'on peut pas les sortir la nuit
[Musique]
la nouvelle loi qui encadre les us
prévoit un mécanisme de surveillance
indépendant nommé par le ministre
fédéral de la sécurité publique les
douze décideurs externes ont le pouvoir
de recommander des changements aux
conditions de confinement et utilement
le retrait du détenu est ce que le
service correctionnel applique bien les
nouvelles règles impossible de le savoir
puisqu'il n'ont pas encore produit de
rapport annuel après 2 ans
par contre des chercheurs mandatés par
le fédéral pour évaluer l'implantation
des unités d'intervention ont conclu que
le service correctionnel n'a pas
respecté la loi pendant la première
année
[Musique]
dans 28% des placements us les détenus
sont sortis moins de deux heures par
jour de leur cellule ce qui équivaut à
l'isolément comme on le connaissait
[Musique]
de cela 10 % répondent aux critères de
torture en vertu des règles de mandela
ils ont eu moins de deux heures de
sortie et ils sont restés plus de quinze
jours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le défi du changement de culture est
présente il faut le reconnaître on y
travaille à tous les jours
aussi on a eu des avis extérieurs qui
nous ont qui nous ont fait des
observations qu'on a pu prendre en
considération mettre les choses en
perspective puis les adresser donc on
est continuellement en train de
s'améliorer
nous voulons voir si cette politique est
mise en oeuvre comme le parlement l'a
prévu
c'est peu prisé d'un nouveau comité
indépendant qui poursuit le travail de
surveillance et nous a fait parvenir en
primeur quelques résultats de son
prochain rapport
depuis la création des us en novembre
2019 jusqu en août dernier mais 732
détenus ont été placés dans les unités
d'intervention
ce qui équivaut à 8,4 pour cent de la
population carcérale
55% ils sont restés plus de 30 jours et
22,5 pour cent entre 60 et 552 jour il
ya pas de limite data il ya vraiment
aucune limite de taille a pas de cap son
petit ainsi ça exaspère le sap le savons
la noc son lock pratiquement depuis le
début l'implantation juive elle demeure
il les a mais en a qui veulent demeurer
comme sap 8e sopi qui plongera aux
sentences pascual
le service correctionnel souligne qu'en
février dernier on ne comptait que 156
détenus dans les us à travers le pays
soit 1,3 pour cent de la population
carcérale
selon haaretz et peuvent les détenus
autochtones et ceux qui ont des
problèmes de santé mentale était se
représenter en cellule d'isolement ils
le sont encore dans les unités
d'intervention structure et d'autres
aspects soulève de nombreuses
interrogations
pourquoi certains prisonniers
bénéficient d'un temps de sortie de
cellule il d'autres pas pourquoi une
région est elle différente d'une autre
pourquoi une présent est elle différente
d'une autre nous voulons creuser plus
profondément nous voulons voir quel est
l'impact sur les femmes par rapport aux
hommes quel est l'impact sur les
autochtones par rapport aux autres sur
des hommes noirs par rapport aux autres
détenus
alors que les huillet c'était encore en
chantier un agent de programmes a
demandé à timothée de partager avec le
personnel correctionnel son expérience
de l'isolément
qu'est ce qui est important ce moment là
pour vous de leur dire le plus important
prenez vata
moi madame je suis à ma vie je suis
kabyle vie aussi les hormones
les victimes je pense qu'un bras va
changer le système mais si gérard
avallone des indices
peut-être améliorer un peu
c'est mieux pour tout le monde mieux
pour les détenus
mieux par le csii poser les questions si
je pense la sci usa un bon repense j'ai
créé avait dit oui et non non c'est par
ce besoin book travaille beaucoup pour
muriaux issa si je cravache juste un nom
pour le pousse dans un bond de radio
je progresse et montant des mises à
gages
vaud
[Musique]
au canada les sénateurs ont tous accès
au pénitencier kempen a constaté sur
place que d'autres forme d'isolement
existe toujours
et qui coming out nunes et je n'arrive
pas à me souvenir de tous les nouveaux
noms qu'ils ont pour les différentes
formes de ségrégation qu'ils autorisent
il n'y a aucune obligation légale de
surveillance pour aucune d'entre elles
c'est ce qu'on a lu dans un pays comme
le canada qui se targue d'être leader en
matière de droite dames
dans son dernier rapport l'enquêteur
correctionnel note la même chose il
existe un large éventail de conditions
et de pratiques d'isolement restrictif
en dehors des huits yes
isolement médical observatoire de la
santé mentale surveillance étroite en
cas de suicide la cellule sèche il ya
plein de régime alternatif qui ressemble
beaucoup quand même pas en prison ce
qu'ils appellent les cellules
comportementale c'est la même chose que
nous allemands c'est juste que ça existe
nulle pa comment ça ça existe et ça
c'est pas écrit dans la loi c'est pas
écrit dans les directives ça existent
pas sur papier donc pas de cadre légal
qui régit ce mais c'est un moyen auquel
ont encore recours pour gérer le
comportement des individus
olivier connaît les cellules
comportementale cette forme d'isolement
qu'on appelle dans le jargon carcéral un
des docks ils étaient enfermés 22 heures
sur 24 dépouillé de tous ses effets
personnels
il comprendra matin sa
gestion en correctionnelle
[Musique]
et qui sont
criminelles
de ta vie thomas klau invités de tout
véritable
deux a le droit
de contrôler
un autre détenu ben jamais nous dit se
trouver actuellement dans une cellule
d'isolement enfants tombent il a demandé
des soins en santé mentale il a des
idées suicidaires il affirme n'avoir
reçu aucun soin et être enfermé dans le
secteur un n de l'établissement port
cartier
était tout seul c'est quand
l'enquêteur correctionnel
yvan singer connaît bien le secteur 1n à
port cartier nous avons obtenu d'une
source le compte-rendu de sa dernière
visite de ce secteur dans ce document il
en ingère considère que ces unités sont
très problématiques et qu'elle offre
dans certains cas des conditions de
détention très restrictives une façon
selon lui pour le service correctionnel
de contourner la loi pour les us
le service correctionnel soutient que
les détenus ils sont sur une base
volontaire et que les conditions de
détention sont les mêmes que celles de
la population régulière
il affirme que l' isolement n'existe
plus ni à port cartier ni ailleurs qu'il
est bel et bien aboli ce que je peux
vous dire c'est qu'on a on a des unités
d'intervention structuré et on a des
populations des unités régulières et au
besoin si les détenus présentent des des
problématiques de santé mentale plus
important nous avons également des
centres de traitement qui sont
essentiellement des hôpitaux qui qui
prennent en charge ces détenus qui
peuvent leur offrir les services
nécessaires
je crois que le système correctionnel
trouvera un moyen d'isoler les
prisonniers lorsqu ils le jugeront
nécessaire que ce soit dans la loi ou
non
je voulais que la possibilité d'avoir
recours est les allemands soit inscrite
dans la loi pour que nous puissions le
surveiller et obliger le service à
rendre des comptes
deux ans et demi après l'entrée en
vigueur de la loi l'isolément se
poursuit derrière des portes closes et
continue d'entraîner des dommages
psychologiques
dont la sénatrice kemp est le
gouvernement n'a pas tenu ses promesses
de mettre fin à l' isolement une
pratique qu'aucun détenu selon elle
numérique
avec moi venez dans les prisons esitmant
lesquels de ces personnes méritent selon
vous d'être traités de cette façon
lorsque nous pouvons déshumaniser les
gens et ne pas les considérer comme nos
voisins nos mères nos enfants nos soeurs
alors il est si facile de les
déshumaniser et de dire que quoi qu'ils
leur arrivent tant pis une fois qu'ils
ont l'étiquette de criminels pour
certaines personnes cela signifie qu'ils
sont jetables
pippo parce qu'il ya des accusations
criminelles que j'ai une personne qui
mérite pas d'avoir des droits et d'avoir
une seconde chance
[Musique]
en